改变自己是神
改变别人呢
是神经病
人呢
一旦开始动了改造别人的念头
你的内心的不甘
你的这些贪念
你的这些矫枉过正就会开始滋生
因为你的潜意识
会疯狂的把身边的这个人
和别人进行彻头彻尾的比较
最后宣布
哎
你想改造的这个人
所以很多的争吵就随之发生
因为所有舒服的关系里边
都没有期待
欢迎来到
其实你看
无论是父母也好
伴侣也好
或者是孩子也好
亦或者是身边的朋友
就是
你想改变谁
都是四个字
你以为改的是对方的一个
我告诉你
其实你要面对的是对方背后支撑的
小到袜子随便乱丢
大到性格懒散
为人不上进
你以为改掉一个习惯很容易
但实际上决定一个人行为的
是对方大脑里边的
你指望父母明事理
对吧
不给自己添堵
不催婚
你只想搞事业
我跟你说
父母听不进去的
他只会觉得生你已经是恩
你不早日成婚
他们就放不下心
你说
我指望另一半上进
多挣钱
对吧
以求提升家庭的这种
抗风险的这么一个能力
那对方可能会觉得
安逸就是福啊
维系现有的生活品质就已经满足了
你奋力上进
反而是在对方眼里边
就是焦虑过度
你说
我指望我的孩子能够更活泼外向一点
和有些孩子一样成为这种社牛
成为人群里边最耀眼的那一个
但也许在孩子的眼睛里边
自己生来性格就内向
他不喜欢和很多人相处
所以你的逼迫
反而会把孩子给推得越来越远
所以你看
人
大多数烦恼的产生
就是来自于自己太想去掌握别人的人生
但凡你只要没意识到
任何一个人都是一个独立的个体
那我告诉你
你心里边改造他们的这种妄想
就会不断的
当然我也相信
无数次的现实的经验
可能已经告诉你了
对吧
一切向外的指望
都是内心期待的
而繁琐期待
多数时候
皆会落空
相反
哪一天你没有期待了
你只拼命的关注自己
爱自己
让他人自由
一切关系
反而舒服
因为有句话说的特别好
不期待
就是在寻找
一个真正成熟的人
他只会执着于抓住生活里边的
什么是确定性？
就是你自己能掌控的一切大小事儿
你可以决定
咱们今天跑个步
咱们今天健个身
读本书
看堂课
这些对你来说都是可控的
但是你无法确保你爱的人
爱不爱你
你挂念的人呢
会不会按照你的想法去生活
你期待的事儿对方会不会照做
如果说你大脑里边天天琢磨的就是这些
那你不就是
亲手在增加生活里边的不确定性吗？
所以反过来
你越擅长排除掉人生里的不可控的那部分
你的内核
就越来越稳
你看那些
不断想摆脱他人情感依赖的人
看似冷漠无常
其实我告诉你
他内在是有
他懂得去追寻不变
而不是说把期待寄托在别人那儿
去增加自己的被
这么一个风险
人生最大的不清醒
就是一切渴望都
一旦抓住某段关系就不松手
在一段关系里边耗尽自己一切的理智和体面
事实上
在这个世界上
任何的关系
都不值得以
来作为延续啊
你是谁
比你待在哪段关系里边
更重要
因为
你
是一切的根源
那些需要费尽心力
才能勉强续存的关系
我告诉你本质上
都是你的内心不够富足
你的心力不够圆满
以至于你
所以请记住
任何需要你去努力经营的关系
都不是
而是
只要是强求来的东西
往往保质期它都不会长的
所以人
只能从自己身上去找答案
你不能指望靠别人来成就
你对这个世界的念想
是不是
钱也好
一个更好的自己也罢
那都得靠自己一步步的挣出来
打磨出来呀
这个世界上任何一段关系的出现
都应该是
而不是
很多时候
残缺状态下的自己
没有人会欣赏
甚至哪怕是我们自己
也会觉得过往的自己难免有些不堪
更有甚者
还会努力和过往那个缺乏力量的自己
去划清界限
只希望别人记得自己好的一面
人性就是如此
但多数时候
人
难免会犯一个错
就是
恰逢自己状态低迷的时候
会倾向于找一个人
或者是
寄托一段关系来拯救自己
把自己从这个低谷里边给打捞出来
而不是说我要选择自己去淌过这趟浑水
走出这个混沌
也许从成本的角度来讲
对吧
选择一条容易走的捷径
攀附上一段关系
可能会让自己迅速的脱胎换骨
但往后这段关系的走向
可不是像一开始那样
事事都让你顺心的呀
你可能要付出讨好
付出委曲求全
才可能让关系延续下去
所以你看
人与人之间的关系
一定要讲究
势均力敌
才能走得更远
不可能你手无寸铁
对方手眼通天
还反过来
需要处处满足你的期待
这不符合现实世界里边的
真实故事走向的呀
所以请记住
一切好的关系的存在
一定是始于双方
而不是一方
我们可以打一句话
双方本身人都是很好的人
有余力去付出的人
我跟你说
关系才会被滋养
就是
你自己有了这个储蓄爱的空间
就好比你在银行里边储蓄
先存
才有取啊
你反观那些让人痛不欲生的关系吧
我跟你说
问题一定是现在
双方内在的贫瘠
因为他只把一段关系
当成是索取的对象
然后拼命的
往兜里捞好处
直到最后关系的崩坏
所以你们就记住一句话
逆着人性走
一切去向内求
就当你越喜欢一个人
你所表现出来的行为就越缺乏理智
滤镜
会让你高看别人
低看自己
你满心期待
最后的结果
往往就是以
人心就是如此
它总会美化这个世界
美化他人
甚至美化任何一条自己从来没有过的路
但就是不肯
好好的花时间
去认真的塑造自我的
于是你看
在这个社会上走了很多年
还是遇到点风雨就会崩溃
对吧
遇到个外人就投降
反正那些真正清醒的人
我跟你说
早就把
给戒掉了
相比
对很多事儿
他怀有期待
但不是件件有着落
何不如就把决定权交还给自身呢
要的东西咱们自己买
需要花钱咱们自己赚
对吧
向往的未来咱们自己造
比起惊喜
一种对人生更有把握感的
我觉得这个才是更值得追求啊
以一种
心态去看待事情
要么
助我成长
要么为我所用
你就会发现内心当中会
生出一般的平静
而且在平静之上
你能够接纳
一切事情的发生
当走到这一步
我告诉你
你已经很强大了
而多数时候
对吧
那个带着你穿越低谷往高处走的人
往往不是别人
而是你自己啊
所以别去期待任何外界的人事物
只需绞尽心力的去摸索
如何让自己的生活周遭
充满着坚不可摧的
你活出坚定
并井井有条
一切关系
反而会变得
那最后送给大家这么一句话
向外求的时候呢
一路上全是风险和荆棘
往内寻
一切
就只剩稳妥和安全感
所有舒服的关系里边
都没有
期待